يا انتكاسات ، سأنتكس هاه ،
لكننا في الموقف الذي نحن فيه بسبب
النكسات وهذا ما هو عليه وبعيدًا
عن الموقف نحن بسبب
الأداء الجيد أيضًا ، لذلك
لم يكن لدى الجميع انتكاسات فقط ولكن
كان لدينا  الكثير مما هو واضح اليوم كان
شخصًا مناسبًا ولا شك في ذلك ، نعم
الآن علينا أن نتركه
وسنتعامل معه ، إنها أشياء ممتعة
تعلمناها في هذا الموسم مع
انتكاسات شريرة ولكن بعد ذلك آه علينا أن
نتأكد من أننا  يتعافى بشكل صحيح لأنه من
الواضح أن لدينا مباراة كبيرة يوم الأربعاء
وكذلك مع
فترة الاستراحة الدولية ، آمل أن يعود الجميع
بصحة جيدة
ومن ثم يتعين علينا أن نذهب إلى
أسبوع كرة القدم
في جميع أسابيع كرة القدم من المنافسين ،
لذا نعم ، هناك الكثير لنفعله ولكن
اليوم ليس الوقت المناسب الآن
للحديث عن أن هذه اللعبة كانت
ضربة قوية